la petite enfance des ménages le 19
février dernier les employés du service
posaient leurs cartons dans leurs
nouveaux locaux face à la mairie un
projet envisagé trois ans plus tôt nous
avons estimé qu' effectivement pour
pouvoir recevoir les administrés dans de
meilleures conditions que ce soit en
terme de qualité d'accueil mais aussi de
confidentialité il était nécessaire
effectivement de de redéployer
d'installer le service sur une autre
structure des anciens locaux rue nadar
trop exigu mais aussi une volonté de
centraliser les différents services de
la ville pour faciliter les démarches
administratives
le service de la petite enfance à que
chaque année près de 300 familles ont le
service petite enfance accueille les
parents qui souhaitent effectivement
faire une première une préinscription
dans le cas d'une demande de places en
crèches et les pré inscriptions se font
à six mois de grossesse pour l'ensemble
des administrés elles reçoivent ensuite
les parents au moment des
renouvellements les anciens locaux rue
nadar sont désormais exclusivement
réservé à l'accueil des assistantes
maternelles